OF BRITNEY EA MHE
AI INTENDSTEP  C
EMND
STEV
STNI
IS LIVE.
ATE LATE
>> WHAT CHANGES ISEW LEGALJAMIE
SPEARS AND INDICATINE D P WNTO
ESTIMATED $60 MILLION ESTATE
WHILE HE DOESN'T THINKHERE AREGU
BUPRBATTLEY
WITH HISR ABOUT THISVATORSHIP IA
TH
T
THAT BRITNEY WAS IN CRISISR TAFA
DATORS AUND AND TARGHEL
WEALTHS WELL. WHY HE'
R, LIKSATTHE
UR IS
MAKI HE SAT  A H JAMIE SPEARST
INVESTIGATIVE ALTHAS UT AND
LEGED EAEDS
DOLLARSERTOHEY WILL CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE.
NDNETHERE IS STILL MORE FIGHTIN
COME, IT SOUNDS LI. IS
BECAUSTH THE
IT IABINHEOM SSH  THE
CONSERVATOR.
BUT
COURTCOULD NORE FOR
AT SOME T R EY IS TAKING IS THIT
ND HAD A
PEENEAL.
SO TT OF N TO P
CRIVIL EXPOSURE BYHE OTHAS WYER.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LR E ARE AND IL
NTD THAT IA
, TO TT HE MAY HAVE EAEDS ORPRI
ED T WT B PHOMO>> AND SO THLAM
YOU ME WHAT YOFALL OEYCHARGES FI
ABUSE.
FALL UNDER ATOLUTELY.THER IT I
CRIMINE ISINTE INVOLD.E MISAPPRI
AND THEY BEDERED TO PAY THOSE K
TO THE
RE SAYING ALLY  STATE OF THGHR
E IS MORE TO BRE A STEPHANIE, B
SHOULD S FOR BRITNEY
BY FANS.LY S F  BACK.SHE DOESN'
IS THERE ANY SENSE T OF
TIFRCT T T TTLES AR?NKD TAKET YS
D MAKEAS OCOT, WANTED.
R PREVIOUSLY COUWY
WANTEDCLOSED AFTER  AND NOW WORO
THST MOVEM